welcome back to CBS Mornings in a few
hours the house will try for a fourth
time to elect a speaker following a day
of Chaos in the Republican party after
three rounds of voting yesterday GOP
Congressman Kevin McCarthy failed to get
the votes needed to win nothing else can
happen in the house until a speaker is
elected yesterday Republicans opposed to
McCarthy's bid did not hold back
as it stands I will not be voting for
Kevin McCarthy a speaker if you want to
drain the swamp you cannot put the
biggest alligator in charge of the
exercise Washington's broken
we're the last ones to know I don't want
any more empty promises I don't want any
more oh don't worry trust us we'll do it
even the guy that wants to be speaker
agrees that Washington is broken
when the house does get back to work
Republican James Comer of Kentucky is
set to chair the oversight committee he
joins us right now good morning how are
you doing I'm well how are you
good so what conversations are you
having with your colleagues about where
the house Speaker race is going from
here
well I think we all have to look at what
we agree on and we agree we need a
speaker we need a speaker today so I
think it's important in political
negotiations that both sides try to
figure out and out here both sides have
dug in the sand and I think we've got to
come up with some type of consensus so
we can elect our speaker and move
forward with their Republican agenda
that the voters overwhelmingly gave us
during the midterms this past November
Congressman it's Vlad uh let me ask you
about this Kevin McCarthy's already made
a number of concessions to these
rebellious members of Congress including
allowing a rule that would allow members
to call a vote to oust the speaker but
you've called those political gimmicks
why do you believe that they're gimmicks
and what else do these members want
well I believe they're gimmicks because
there's not going to be a majority of
Republicans ever support this motion to
vacate if we have a scenario where the
speaker does something so bad I can
assure you what's going to happen is
we're going to conference we're going to
encourage the speaker to resign that's
what normally would happen up here but
look if if they want to go all in and
you know draw a line in the sand over
the motion to vacate I'm fine with that
but at the end of the day if I were
negotiating for the speaker of the house
and if I were going to you know so this
crowbar in the whole political process
right now I believe I would try to
jockey for something a little more
substantive I would be focused more on
policy look we're all frustrated
Congress is broken but when you look
Kevin McCarthy's never had an
opportunity to be speaker of the house I
think Kevin's being blamed for the sins
of the past speakers and I think Kevin's
gotten the message look if if you don't
work with all factions of the Republican
conference then you know you're going to
face Peril and I think that that was
played out yesterday
Congressman it's Adriana you just talked
about what you would be asking for and
making that more policy focused but what
is it that these holdouts really are
trying to get from uh the speaker in
terms of further concessions and you
know I've heard a lot of vague theories
on this but if there isn't a tangible
list of requests how do we even move
forward from here well it's very
difficult I've been a part of the
negotiations of many of these guys serve
on my committee and the ones who don't
are trying to get on the oversight
committee this this next year and I
really have a lot of respect for these
guys they're some of the most talented
members of our conference they're very
passionate in their beliefs
unfortunately I believe a lot of this is
personal but look the the conference
overwhelmingly supports Kevin McCarthy
and you know yesterday was a great
display in democracy the American people
got to see play out what this whole
Congress was created for the debate
rigorous debate and somehow tried to get
to a consensus now we add the rigorous
debate part down last night but we
didn't get to the consensus part
hopefully we will today Republicans are
different than Democrats you know we
think independently we're we're not
puppets on the string so it's going to
be a lot of uh back and forth and a lot
of uh infighting to try to get to 218 on
important issues but I think we're going
to do it and I hope yesterday was a good
exercise in helping everyone learn look
we've got to get to 218. nobody's going
to get everything that they want I I
don't think Kevin McCarthy's the perfect
speaker but I believe he's the right
person to lead our conference at the
right time
Congressman yes uh Republicans do think
independently I believe that's the
reason for some of these fractions that
we're seeing amongst the GOP does it
frustrate you that you can't start the
oversight committee and what do you plan
to do from here
well certainly uh we can't send our
letters requesting information we can't
start our depositions we can't start
interviewing people until we become a a
formal committee I'm technically not a
member of Congress right now none of us
are so we've got to elect a speaker the
speaker then turns around and swears in
all the other members of Congress then
we'll sit down and and try to populate
the Committees much of this stuff is
done during the lame duck session
between Thanksgiving and Christmas
unfortunately we're a little bit behind
because of the uncertainty dealing with
the speaker of the house but look we've
got a big agenda we've got a very big
legislative agenda and a big oversight
agenda and and if you look at what's
happened in Congress over the past three
years we spent hundreds of billions if
not trillions of dollars in the name of
covid and there have been you know no
oversight hearing so we want to get
focused on waste fraud abuse and
mismanagement in the federal government
starting with our tax dollar dollars and
that's going to be our very first
hearing once we officially get the
Committees populated and can move
forward so Congressman just big picture
here how how much are you worried that
for the first time in 100 years your
party was not able to elect a house
speaker and what that says to the
American people about our government
I'm not worried I'm honestly not worried
I think that we will get a speaker I
believe it was a great display in in
democracy people can see what really
goes on you know I think there's a lot
of misconceptions about how Congress
works that one or two people make
decisions and the rest of us follow with
what you saw yesterday and what you're
seeing play out right now this morning
and throughout the day will be
negotiations of every member of Congress
you know a lot of what but Congressman
respectfully respectfully the business
of the people cannot be done until you
elect a Speaker of the House of
Representatives and so that's why I'm
wondering if the American people are
going to look and see what is happening
here and say to themselves well you
folks are not really doing the job that
we sent you to Washington to do I don't
think one day he's going to create any
type of hardships for
Republicans passing a conservative
agenda or providing oversight to the
Biden Administration certainly I wish we
could have gotten the the speakership
out of the way yesterday I'm confident
we'll get it done either today or
tomorrow and hopefully we can move
forward after that not a lot
traditionally happens the first week
anyway
that's optimistic let's see how long it
takes Congressman Comer thank you